yes good afternoon that wallet hi how
can we help you yes I'm calling because
I am using the youngevity product and I
have several chronic conditions one
being high blood pressure I have some
liver damage and kidney damage and also
have some heart free from the chronic
diseases I'm diabetic as well my
question is there is chromium something
that I should be concerned with
regarding my kidney kated Tanjung
tangerine which i am taking the 3ds and
the selenium you have chromium is that
something that should be a concern for
me
well deficiencies of those minerals
should be a concern to you because heart
disease can be caused by deficiencies of
them certainly liver disease can be
caused by deficiencies of them kidney
disease not so much a diabetes of course
can be deficiencies of them alright and
so how much you weigh I weigh about a
hundred and five okay so you're small
how tall are you
five six we were very thin if you're
five six anyway 105 you're very slim
that correct
hello that's our business yes I'm here
can you hear me I can I could hear
you're very slim very skinny yes and I
actually have done some weight so okay
let me ask you a couple of questions
real quick do you have any history of
having asthma as a kid or bronchitis no
asthma bronchitis
what about skin comes any eczema
dermatitis psoriasis rosacea no none of
those okay did you ever have your
appendix out
no appendix out okay do you ever have
bowel problems constipation diarrhea
irritable bowel syndrome diverticulitis
colitis that I think every relative to
my liver I think during the time that I
was ill before I was you know diagnosed
with the liver cirrhosis of the liver I
did have that and what I also had young
early on in my twenties was a
hyperactive thyroid okay yeah when a
person has diabetes kidney problems
liver problems I would pressure thyroid
problems heart problems this these are
all nutritional deficiency problems
these are all nutritional deficiency
problems and usually there's a
malabsorption problem there oftentimes
the more common reasons for a
malabsorption problem is a gluten
problem okay we have a an intolerance
not an allergy to wheat but intolerance
of gluten wheat brought around oats do
you have any children yes I have two
biological children okay and did they
have any asthma bronchitis or skin
problems or bowel problems not really
they do have allergies
okay what about any sisters and brothers
I had yes I have sisters and brothers
might have a sister that has asthma so
this her son okay that's enough we got
it now and so this shows up in varying
ways and different people some people to
get allergies some people get a headache
some people get skin from some people
have asthma
and so you got all the different stuff
going on with your family whether
they're siblings and nieces and nephews
your own kids and so forth yourself and
so I want you to start out by getting
rid of all the bad stuff get rid of all
the bad stuff no fried foods I mean
nobody in the house can have fried foods
you got to get rid of all the processed
meat so we're talking about things like
deli slices sandwich meats sausage ham
bacon Bologna salami pastrami pepperoni
jerky carnby spam all that's got to go
no oils that means no microwave popcorn
no theater popcorn absolutely no olive
oil no coconut oh no margins mayonnaise
hundreds of cooking oils and then no
gluten no wheat no bra no ten clues dog
food cat food bird food fish food
mother-in-law a renter anybody staying
in your house has to be gluten free okay
then at 105 pounds I would have you take
one healthy brain and heart pack per
month one healthy brain and heart pack
per month take a half a dose of
everything at breakfast and dinner
except for the selenium I would have you
take get an extra bottle of slim so you
could take six a day to eat breakfast
two at lunch to a dinner time that's
going to help support heart function and
heart maintenance repair is going to
support liver function and liver
maintenance repair and then I would also
have you take three of the ultimate
daily classic tablets twice a day
there's two bottles a month of the
ultimate daily classic tablets and
they're designed to support promote
healthy blood pressure support promote
healthy kidney function by supporting
healthy blood flow through the kidneys
also again support healthy heart
function and then because of the
diabetes I would get one bottle of the
sweeties and one bottle of the glucose
in it
Luka genex take three of those capsules
of the sweeties at breakfast and three
tablets of the glucose genic to
dinnertime and then lastly for the
thyroid I would get the oceans gold and
I would go ahead and take three of those
twice as it would be two bottles a month
and stay away also in addition to the
fried foods processed meats oils and
glutens also stay away from crucifer
vegetables that means a cabbage broccoli
cauliflower Brussels sprouts and kale